Researchers have figured
out how bad memories
are erased from the
brain, which is great,
because I have to forget
this thing that happened
in the desert before
court tomorrow.
Anthony here for D News.
And I think we've all
wondered just when we'll
be able to Eternal Sunshine
all the nasty stuff out
of our memories-- you know,
visit a doctor, pop a pill,
and proof.
Whatever traumatic stuff
is messing with you,
it's just gone.
You know, the secret to
getting over a painful memory
lies in a process
called memory extension.
Over time, it becomes
easier to walk by the place
where your break up happened
because the traumatic memory
of that place is replaced
by all the more recent ones
where nothing happened
while you walked by there.
But what physical process
causes memory extinction?
What makes those
painful memories fade?
A new study
published by MIT says
it all lies in a gene
called Tet1, which
controls the expression of
other genes in your hippocampus
and cortex-- two
bits of your brain
that are important to
learning and memory.
Two groups of mice were studied.
One had a normal level
of Tet1, one group
had its ability to
make Tet1 removed.
And all of the mice
were put into a cage
and given an electric shock.
And then over time, they
kept being put into the cage,
but without ever
being shocked again.
And the mice with
normal Tet1 levels
eventually were not
stressed out by the cage.
But the mice without Tet1
never stopped being frightened.
And it's not that
the mice without Tet1
couldn't make new memories.
They seemed to learn and
remember new things just fine.
But memory extinction
is not actually
about old memories
disappearing, it's
about having both the old and
new memories and your brain
being able to phase
is the old one
out as it becomes less relevant.
The mice without Tet1
couldn't do that.
The two memories existed just
as powerfully at the same time.
So no Tet1 means
bad memories never
lost their importance
or clarity.
But what happens if you can
boost someone's levels of Tet1?
The MIT researchers
believe it could
lead to new treatments for
things like addiction and PTSD,
and maybe one day trickle
down into a pill that
helps take the sting out of
some of the other traumatic life
events that are
hard to get over.
There are probably some other
things to figure out there too,
I'd imagine, like does Tet1
just wash away all old trauma?
Can we really create
something that
can just target one
specific memory?
I love this idea as
a form of therapy
for people who have had
extremely traumatic events
in their life, but I hate to
see it become too widely used.
I mean, imagine a future
where we have the ability
to decide how important
every event in our life
is and just ditch the ones that
we don't think are relevant.
I feel like that's
kind of a recipe
for a society full of
overconfident dummies.
I don't know what.
Do you think?
Would you use a
memory removal pill?
Let us know in the comments
and subscribe for more D News.